Коли, наприклад,
ти сидиш на стільцях,
ну, наприклад, в Нью-Йорку
чи якомусь аеропорту, чи в готелі,
чи в кафе в Австралії чи в Китаї,
вони українські,
з українським кодом,
і це відчувається...
Це...
Це впливає.
Faina — це колекція
українського живого дизайну.
Живий дизайн — це зв'язок з природою,
зі своїм корінням та із собою.
Взагалі, в моєму житті
мало що з'явилося спеціально.
[сміється]
Все воно йшло якось інтуїтивно.
Взагалі, я часто кажу,
що це не я створила Faina,
це Faina обрала мене.
Це й початок Faina,
і як вона народилася.
Це був 2014 рік.
Це був той період, той час,
дуже важливий для України,
період, коли була Революція Гідності.
Саме в цей період я чітко відчула
потребу щось зробити для України.
І коли ти їдеш у машині,
і ти, з одного боку, чуєш,
що відбувається на Сході твоєї країни,
а, з іншого боку, ти чуєш,
що європейський світ занепокоєний.
У цей час ти дуже чітко розумієш,
що ти нікому не потрібен,
і що твоя країна, крім тебе,
теж нікому не потрібна.
І ти собі ставиш питання:
«Що ти можеш зробити для...?».
Я захотіла масштабувати щось,
що могло би бути у всьому світі,
і так з'явилася Faina.
І чому промисловий дизайн?
Тому що його можливо
масштабувати.
Це був перший етап.
Коли це в мене народилось,
але я не знала, що з цим робити.
Faina — це ж не про красу тільки ззовні,
це про «зсередини».
Ми називаємо нашу філософію
філософією живого дизайну.
Все, що ми робимо, живе.
Наприклад, ми використовуємо вовну,
ми використовуємо глину.
Тільки натуральні тканини,
ми використовуємо лозу.
Все, що робиться,
робиться руками.
У нас взагалі все дуже просто.
Матеріал ztista,
тому що ти ліпиш як з тіста,
Soniah, тому що він як сонях,
Strikha, тому що вона як стріха.
Все, чим я надихалася, — це була
українська культура, традиції, природа.
Всі літні канікули я проводила
в Донецькій області.
Це було справжнє дитинство
зі справжніми традиціями.
Наприклад, Трійця
чи Івана Купала з вінками.
Це те, що мене надихало
з самого початку.
Ідея — це дуже мало.
До 2018 року це були постійні
дуже великі інвестиції,
та майже кожен місяць
я хотіла з цим закінчити.
Я заробляла на архітектурі
і все-все-все інвестувала у Faina.
Це було дуже багато спроб,
це було дуже багато підрядників,
це були муки в буквальному
сенсі цього слова,
тому що це ненормально,
коли ти щодня, маючи
багато дітей, сім'ю, бізнес,
ти не з'являєшся ніде,
а ти весь свій час, енергію,
гроші вкладаєш у це.
У мене майже ніхто не вірив,
і я навіть сама в себе
не до кінця вірила,
тому що всі казали:
«Ну, так, гарно. І що?».
Я навіть хотіла свої ідеї, свої меблі
віддати іншим меблевикам,
італійським, за роялті (це нормальна
практика), щоб вони їх виготовляли.
Але я розуміла,
що вони зміняться,
це буде вже інша історія.
Все, що я робила, —
це було зсередини.
Незрозуміло,
ні для кого, ні для чого.
Це була моя внутрішня місія.
Перша виставка була
в Болоньї, 2015 рік.
Що було важливо, що от
ми повезли туди комод, наприклад,
і в нас був попит,
в нас питали ціну,
але все, що нас питали,
ми були до цього не готові.
Ну, наприклад, скільки коштує
доставка, який у вас прайс.
І ми відповідали, але все, що ми
відповідали, ми чітко розуміли,
що це ну так якось,
не дуже професійно.
Тобто це була дуже-дуже
гарна школа,
щоб зрозуміти,
на якому етапі ти перебуваєш,
і що в тебе взагалі нічого нема,
крім твоєї ідеї,
а це ну така собі історія.
2018 року змінилося те,
що ми зрозуміли, хто ми,
і нас для нас відкрили шведи.
Дякую шведам!
[сміється]
Це вже була четверта наша виставка.
Взагалі-то, ми були
на виставках до цього,
всі казали: «Ой, які ви гарні!»,
але ж ніхто нічого не купував!
Коли ми приїхали до Швеції,
вони були в повному захваті.
Шведські ЗМІ написали (дослівно):
«Що ми знали про український
дизайн? Нічого!
Але ми побачили Faina,
ми хочемо більше Faina!»
Нам приписують багато чого,
бо коли ми з'явилися,
в такій стилістиці
ще ніхто не працював.
Ми з самого початку чули
завжди одну й ту ж фразу:
«Гм, що це?
Це не схоже ні на що!».
Тобто в голові у всіх
не було такого штампу.
Зрозуміло, як виглядає
італійський дизайн,
як французький,
шведський, а що оце?
Повз нас неможливо було пройти.
Дивувала саме ця несхожість,
і це зупиняло.
2018 року американський
Vogue [написав],
[що] ми увійшли у список
«11 хедлайнерів інтер'єрного ринку».
Тобто ми ще ось тільки тут починаємо,
а вже ми хедлайнери.
Ми не стали зірками,
але ми зрозуміли,
що те, що нам говорять,
що ми подобаємося,
це вже по-справжньому.
І з цього моменту,
з 2018 року,
ми почали вже свідомо
вибудовувати наш бренд.
Також ми зрозуміли,
хто наша авдиторія,
тому що в нас купили предмети,
і це була зовсім інша ніша.
Взагалі, історія Faina
почалася зі стільця,
але його зараз немає,
і він був дуже, як на мене
зараз, нестильний.
Це були мої перші спроби,
і, взагалі-то, ми їх навіть
продали, чотири стільці.
Але потім вже пішли речі з глини.
Це комод,
наш найперший,
ми його не продаємо,
він побував усюди.
Він [виготовлений] 2015 року,
і він вже навіть реставрувався.
Тобто це наш перший комод,
наш символ, і ось ми його зберігаємо.
Ситуацій, котрі окуповувались моїм часом
чи грошима, чи нервами, дуже-дуже багато.
Напевно, найчастіше — це все ж таки підрядники.
Тобто ти робиш креслення,
ти їх віддаєш підряднику,
ти йому даєш аванс.
Потім він тобі виготовляє,
а це зовсім не те,
що ти йому намалював.
І ти повинен йому заплатити,
тому що він зробив,
ну, як зміг, але зробив,
і ти не хочеш цього скандалу,
і так сім разів.
Перші чотири і далі п'ятий рік, мабуть,
навіть шостий — це були досі інвестиції,
тому що були виставки,
виробництва, зарплати.
Меблі не продавалися.
Я думаю, що це, напевно,
все ж таки 2019 рік, початок 2020 року,
коли вже ми могли собі
дозволити більше.
Ми постійно з'являємося
в різних трендах.
І я дуже пишаюся тим,
що, наприклад, минулого року
в такому виданні, як Dezeen,
найвпливовішому в нашій сфері.
Воно опублікувало
«7 трендів інтер'єрного року»,
і серед них були й ми.
Так було й написано:
«Український дизайн від Faina».
Поїхати на виставку може кожен,
туди можна їздити постійно,
рік-два-три,
але потрапити до трендів —
це вже говорить про те,
що експерти не тільки
тебе визнають,
вони тобі говорять:
«Ось тренди на майбутнє».
І ми в цих трендах
вже кілька років постійно,
в різних країнах,
в різних трендбуках.
Монобрендові шоуруми в нас
на сьогодні тільки в Брюсселі та Києві.
В інших країнах — це представники.
Тобто ми є в 44 країнах.
Ми будемо відкривати більше
монобрендових шоурумів.
А в Бельгії з'явився простір
наприкінці 2019 року в Брюсселі.
Наш дизайн відчувають,
його розуміють.
Ми є в дуже різних країнах.
Наприклад, той же Китай,
котрий не дуже полюбляє меблі
з іншими культурними кодами,
тому що в них свій дуже сильний,
вони нас дуже гарно прийняли.
Ми майже по всьому світу.
У серпні 2018 року якось я прокинулася:
«Хочу зробити дизайн-експедицію».
Що це таке?
Дизайн-експедиція — це коли ти привозиш найвпливовіших
дизайн-експертів (це архітектори чи ЗМІ) в Україну,
щоб вони надихнулися.
Але не просто ти їх возиш,
розповідаєш,
а щоб вони зробили
щось своїми руками,
щоб вони відчули
цю енергетику і для того,
щоб вони потім повернулися до себе
і стали нашими амбасадорами.
І ось так ми зробили першу,
а потім і другу дизайн-експедицію.
У першій дизайн-експедиції
у нас був Роберто Бачокі.
Це архітектор, котрий робить інтер'єри
та будівлі Prada по всьому світу.
Він співпрацює не тільки з Prada,
а й з іншими брендами.
Це була Анна Ліна Лено,
котру ще називають королевою шведського дизайну.
Тобто найвпливовіші ресурси,
найвпливовіші дизайн-експерти.
Вони захотіли побачити,
що ж там в тій Україні такого,
що в ній ось ця Faina є.
Їм було цікаво!
Ми для них відкривали
ось цю дизайн-Україну,
ми її відкривали не поїздкою до Києва,
а поїздкою по Закарпаттю,
по Львівській області,
у нас там п'ять днів.
Їм показати трембіти,
їм показати наші бандури,
їм показати, як в Гавареччині ліпити
і що це таке чорнодимлена кераміка.
Тобто ми зробили такий
більш масштабний крок,
більш таку освітню роботу.
Не тільки для зовні,
а й для нас.
Щоб ми самі, українці,
побачили, що ми цікаві,
що наші ремесла, наші традиції,
наші форми цікаві.
І ми хотіли, щоб ці дизайн-експерти
навчили самих ремісників,
як можна їхній матеріал, їхні форми,
їхні переваги використовувати.
І показувати, як можливо
ось це все робити стильним.
І якщо це показувати,
то це все буде розвиватися.
Наприклад, шведська дизайнерка плете
на цьому станку якісь інші форми.
Наша українка дивиться:
«А як вона це робить?
Що вона робить? Так не можна!»,
а потім вона...
Спочатку «так не можна»,
а потім вона бачить, як можна,
і вже вона росте,
і в неї вже ширший світогляд.
І ось ця дизайн-експедиція показала,
що [є] цінного і для всіх учасників процесу.
Про що наш дизайн?
Про те, наскільки світу
не вистачає бути справжнім,
бути інакшим,
бути десь, може, наївним.
Дизайн задля дизайну
взагалі нікому не потрібен.
Він повинен вирішувати
якісь питання.
Ти повинен дати таке,
чого нема.
Ось коли ти зможеш це дати,
тоді це спрацює.
Коли ми десь на виставках,
чи ми спілкуємось з іноземцями,
чи не тільки з іноземцями,
ми завжди розповідаємо
про наше коріння,
і ми розповідаємо
через наші предмети,
через наше мистецтво,
через нашу творчість.
І це завжди як культурна
дипломатія працює,
тому що ти не розповідаєш, з чого це
вироблено, про його функціонал і все.
Ти розповідаєш історію.
Тож ми завжди цим ділимось і дуже надихаємо
іноземців такими моментами.